ragazzi io questo vi questo video lo
faccio partire dalla schermata di steam
perché mi devo fare le cose in parte
proprio gioco come ischia ci gioca
quindi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma cos'è vorrei bellissimo bene a tutti
ragazzi benvenuti che sono video sono su
star pictures files
io non ho idea di che cosa se non ho
idea azzurro di cosa sia non lo so high
un punto e clip anonimo ma cos'è così
era lento il tempo così parlò con la
buongiorno
no sono entrato dentro un posto non
volevo neanche entrarci
sono talmente bassi che non entra
nell'inquadratura va bene c'è veramente
scritto quello che penso puoi comprare
delle pillole per ingrandire il bene non
ne ho bisogno dove comprare delle copie
piratate di icarly season 2 e blu ray
cosa ci fanno le di scotti città stiamo
cercando di guadagnare la il badge
guastafeste della città
io non ho capito veramente di che cosa
stiamo parto sesta roba è solo l'incipit
era veramente buono salve che cosa me ne
frega chiaro l pikes peak è una mazzata
ma perché è fratello perché c'è un
cappello così lungo io devo randellare i
maiali in tutto questo c'è chi sta
suonando che fastidio madonna entriamo
nel vangelo di maiali salve ma povero
maiale vuoi gianpi norway up ma perché
devo fare questa cosa mi scusi signor
maiale la colpisco piano e lo fa la
forza forte mi dispiace devo farlo forte
sono mi rompono vuol giampo
bolgia don kick design non rompere
questa scritta va bene e devo per forza
farlo performance tronchi ok e non posso
romperla haqiq non calciare scusami
oddio oddio a ok mi serviva per fare
propulsione ok va bene ci sono pro
pulsato di in alto ma che gioco era che
ama cosa sto già vieni qua tu vabbè dai
mi dispiace cosa facevo dentro squadra
c'è un caso dico ad allora scotti non
devo ora non vorrei run dell'arti maiale
salve non vorrei run dell'arti ma me lo
fanno fare mi dispiaceva molto triste
vedere roland dello e mi dispiace me lo
fanno fare visto fare gioco finito col
sangue sono sporco di seb è chiaro
questo sembra cattivo non è proprio il
massimo
malvagio non sono fatto per un qualcosa
meglio di questo magari fai lo youtube
non so cosa dire visto i trigger a un
falco sto gioco lega solutions si può
uscire molto bene genera tra spazzatura
da puntare l'appunto vicino ad android e
ogni tanto la gente che stava fuori se
n'è andata in b glielo spiaccicata
demetz veramente desidero non essere qui
adesso mio dio ma poverino non lo sento
proprio il film questo film negativo
veramente brutto e quindi che devo fare
mi dispiace che piange lo so che non
vorresti lamellare maiali per il resto
della tua vita anche perché forse sei
pure vegano però superiore di legali
salve
sei un perdente proprio io asciuga le
tue lacrime i bambini che piangono non
vanno in paradiso non è vero ti sto
dando la chance per una per una vita
sono un fuorilegge un cowboy veramente
moderno
mi chiamo zambesi zambrotta potevamo
essere qualcosa allora torna al lavoro
veloce
sento la campana che ti chiama in via
proprio il culo aveva no non voglio c'è
questa android che ancora morto in my
name is ma basta
grazie dio 6 mosconi perché ho bisogno
di coprirmi bisogno di correre questo
weekend gli hai pilli andiamo a guardare
il nuovo star wars più blu
che cosa succede se cosa succederebbe a
questo posto seguiti se me ne andassi ma
comunque questo storia e tipo un
ecosistema non puoi cambiare la roba che
c'è intorno così trasferiamo se vuoi
andare chi sarà il nuovo inserviente di
billy bob come puoi negare a questo
giovane uomo la gioia della compagnia si
vabbè allora come si vedrà come è bello
ora come bello billy bob ascoltabili pop
e le voglio randellate nei denti
sta per entrare qualcuno in modo che
stando alla finestra lo sento
[Musica]
billy budd nicchia con la macchia mio
dio dio morando acito i soldi non
dobbiamo portare via nient'altro rapido
rapido e vabbè la madonna
[Musica]
salve a non siete compagni pensavo fosse
la stessa crew chi diavolo 6 esci da qua
non vedete non vedi che stiamo rapinando
questo posto semplicemente cercando un
drink e idiota ti finiremo in questo
momento se non uscirà questo
fottutissimo posto ma lo fa incazzare
nemmeno io tropic va bene celo celo celo
la faccio sono morto non ce l'avevo
arcavacata figlio perché comando questo
c'è da quando fu aspetta la squadra mi
fa schivare i proiettili fenomeno vuole
a settimana dopo sto vedendo ragazzi
oddio sono un apprendista non sembra più
pinocchio questo posto è perfetto
esattamente cosa stavo cercando a devo
scegliere quale tra i due ma io rimango
sul mio
ma basta oddio a sono più forte con me
che conta mesi vorrei sono pinocchio
high end pinocchio flowers con la
madonna
c'è un cerchio ai piedi con l'evocazione
di satana sul culo aiuto ma torna con la
pistola che uccise aumento poteva andare
oddio no ma no dall inizio anno che non
è dall'inizio mi piace le musiche che
utilizzano il suo gioco non hanno un
senso
oddio no no è morto ce l'ho fatta a alla
faccia di zan forcole monica potevi
anche darmi una mano zambesi maledizione
a madonna come l'ho fatta questa
sembrano kibil bellissima public morto
sull arco si sta facendo sempre più
difficile ragazzi erano un bordello di
proietti rai ha apposto
che poi il mio stile dare spallate è
esattamente questo basta a effetto
ocio
12 occhio che non mi spara
dai te che mi ha sparato prima aiuto
ok a posto ma siamo usciti ce l'ho fatta
ma che gioco e ci spiega cosa sto
giocando
cos'è a cosa sto giocando è la cosa più
trash che io abbia mai visto nella
storia con la grafica di under the
colorata c'è più o meno lo stesso spunto
nella porta faccio fuori potito qualche
urlo vinile poi cala non ho mai saputo
di essere così forte da poter far fuori
qualcuno con una porta modo così triste
subito per morire sei tu l'idea di
questo posto devo confiscare questo
posto per i taurus mi dispiace quello
senso l'ho girato ma continua a fare
quello che stanno facendo
mi piace a una cappa come lo faccio
fuori di vara un sacco fortissimo
ho colpito colpito di nuovo ai anni ho
capito ora sto perdendo lo capisco
proprio lui primo tentativo
proprio lui lo apre lo fa o no ce la fa
ma no esistenza hybrid garantisce per
favore se puoi provare a reclamare
questo posto come se fosse tuo
seppellisci me i miei uomini nel
giardino quindi il suo urban center due
fatti fuori proprio loro quindi sto
gioco consiste nel far fuori dalla gente
senza un motivo c'è far fuori le gang
salvo raga per continuare nel prossimo
episodio perché però mi chiamo però
perché la posso che essere un po punk
sb shift keying prova bestia che gli
sono un po minchia skillet in the long
and bass vi sia piaciuto continua nel
prossimo episodio gang beach
iscrivetevi alla gang se siete se siete
dei veri boys e noi come sempre ci
vediamo in del prossimo shake and peace
[Musica]